[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur dia gonal tv
spécial débutants on va voir aujourd'hui
comment se comporte le roi au jeu
d'échecs est une pièce fondamentale avec
ninon maisuradze et maître international
vos journaux
bonjour le roi c'est la pièce
fondamentale du jeu d'échecs
oui c'est qui et c'est lui qui commande
entre guillemets c'est lui qui - c'est
le roi quoi voilà le roi c'est le roi
c'est le roi d'échiquier alors comment
on va voir comment se déplacent le roi
aujourd'hui on va voir comment se
déplacent loin comment on peut faire
échec au roi oui parce que tout le monde
a entendu parler des faits comment mais
si on sait pas qu'est ce que ça veut
dire où ça veut dire c'est un peu
dommage est évidemment et puis l'échec
et mat
mais c'est que matt qu'est ce que c'est
que l'échec et mat qui veut dire le roi
s'associe avec le donc le bout de ses
joues d'ailleurs que vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas encore c'est ça le donc
beau final deux échecs de fermes at on
laissé là que vous serez bancaire donc
on va commencer peut-être tout de suite
oui on va voir à notre échiquier avec
regardez ici donc on a une position très
simple on a mis quand même deux pions
donc il ya deux rois on va voir déjà
comment se déplacent leur ont alors
c'est très simple ici on gardé par le
roi blanc ici en fait le roi se
dépassent d'une case tout autour de lui
voilà donc c'est très simple il peut
aller sur toutes ces cases l'a donc par
exemple que jouer roi en d4 il peut je
crois ici en donc voilà sur toutes ces
cases là donc il peut aller partout sur
ces casses vers l'or par contre il ya
une réelle c'est qu' il ne peut pas
aller sur évidemment toujours comme les
autres pièces à part le cavalier il peut
pas aller sur les cases de son propre
camp wim et il ne peut pas non plus se
mettre en échec
donc ça c'est ainsi pour un autre thème
oui
donc on a juste dans ces cours vous
apprend comment faire l'essai chez
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais on a
juste commencé déjà vous initier donc
aux échecs c'est que l'euro est une
pièce qui peut pas se permettre aux
êtres en semaine as donc être en prison
en prise en plus de l'homme vers voilà
oui parce que ce à quoi il sert à
menacer il est obligé on vous explique
juste après soit se déplacer etc
mais on ne peut pas entraîner capturer
le roi swazi la partie thermique en
capture le roi mais en réalité non parce
que on n'a pas droit touché le roi est
en eux et retirer des filles
oui donc voilà on vous expliquait
maintenant donc un petit pot alors
imaginons imaginons que les blancs
jouent le coup ici ce coup là c'est au
noir de jouer regardez l'europe bouger
seront ici alors il ne peut pas il peut
aller sur toutes les cases a priori
autour de lui ses 15 lapin sauf que là
il ne peut pas aller sur cette case là
pourquoi pas ce qui est un pion de son
propre camp est ce qui peut prendre le
pion ici oui elle peut prendre
il peut donc y a pas de problème mais
par contre il va avoir un problème silva
sur cette case là le pop art est allé
sur cette case là pourquoi n'y a à
droite donc lis ici d'ailleurs à cause
du pions blancs puisque le pion blanc
comme on a vu dans une autre émission le
pion prend sur les diagonales sur les
diagonales et donc ici le roi serait
emprise du pion et donc ça c'est
interdit par le jeu
on dit qu'il est en prison qu'il est en
échec donc fait c'est pas possible de se
mettre le roi en échec c'est interdit
par les règles tout simplement si vous
faites un tel coût d'un grand tournoi ça
s'appelle un coup illégal et ça dépend
si c'est une partie de liszt vous serez
perdante si votre adversaire et glam que
vous avez fait un coup illégal dans les
partis l'ont que vous pouvez vous
pénalisez parfois c'est à dire enlever
de votre temps cinq minutes et serra il
ya différentes sanctions dit zone pour
les cours légal si vous adversaires ne
marquent pas c'est cool rigole ça existe
aussi entre les amis vous fait d'un coup
personne ne voit que ses surprises dans
ces cas la partie continue voilà donc
ici on voit sur les casses vers toutes
les cases où le roi peut aller il peut
prendre le pion par exemple aussi mais
ne peut pas les nids sur cette case
évidemment parce qu'il ya un pion de son
propre camp n'y allez sur cette case ici
puisqu'il serait emprise du pion ni ici
un coup illégal puisqu'il serait aussi
en prise du haut qui ont alors on va
voir maintenant de façon plus générale
ce que c'est qu'un échec là on a vu ici
que le pion pouvait faire échec mais on
ne peut pas donner échec c'est au noir
de jouer en fait donc c'est les noirs
qui se mettra en échec ils n'ont pas le
droit de le faire donc on va voir
comment nous quand on peut le faire on
peut faire échec
un véritablement alors voici une
position où il ya toutes les pièces bien
qu'on a pu qu'on a pu voir au cours de
ces leçons il ya toutes les pièces sont
disponibles ya des pions il ya des tours
enfin il ya une tour et un cavalia 2
cavaliers un blanc un noir il ya de fous
et il ya des pions dont il ya toutes les
pièces évidemment les rois ici si vous
savez sur une cour vous retrouvez toutes
les pièces que vous connaissez déjà
voilà alors par exemple les blancs ici
pourrait jouer le roi blanc sur toutes
les cases ici a aucun problème
oui mais ils peuvent aussi tenter de
faire un échec sur le roi non alors
comment on fait un échec sur le renoir
quelles sont les possibilités
il suffit de en fait de mettre ce roi
emprise donc par exemple par le fou fou
qu'est sur bedo alors ce fou par exemple
peut aller on a vu dans les leçons
précédente en diagonale donc sur
notamment sur toutes ces cases là et
regarder si le fou vient sur la case de
5 c au noir de jouer et il faut qu'ils
jouent pourquoi pas ce que l'euro
endroit regarder il est sous l'emprise
du fou c'est à dire si les noirs
jouer un coup de pions ici vous aurez
peu n'ont pas le droit de le faire
puisque le roi sevré emprise du fou le
coup d'après donc c'est interdit quand
on est en échec il faut parer les
chaînes wii donc pour que vous comprenez
mieux on vous donner un petit exemple
par exemple dans cette position il avait
joué fou sur g7
c'est possible dès par exemple g7 là on
l'a on attaque le food adversaire donc
si c'est un autre coup le prochain coup
on reprend donc ça s'appelle menace et
l'échec c'est à vos problèmes chose que
menace sauf que comme c'est le roi qui
est menacée il ya juste un dénomination
particulier échec faire un chèque fait
un chèque ce que veut dire aussi menacer
le roi c'est aussi il est obligatoire de
paris la menace alors que là on peut
laisser loit là et on a le droit de
laisser le fou emprise absolument
donc il ya une obligation qui suit par
contre vous pouvez pas laisser vos rois
dans ce cas vous abandonner ou voilà
donc par exemple ici les noirs pourrait
jouer cavalier là on peut prendre le fou
par contre évidemment si on joue le coup
échec
vous n'avez pas de rejouer le cavalier
ici puis nous laisser votre route vous
pourrez prendront alors comment on part
en échec puisque là on est en échec il
faut pas rester cheikh comment on fait
pour leur part et il ya trois moyens
pour en principe à empêcher les chèques
ou ses protégés donc première moyens
cesse de placer tout simplement alors se
déplacer alors est ce qu'on peut se
déplacer aller sur notre gaz
alors allez sur une autre case où le roi
ne serait pas en prise à lens qu'on
pourrait venir ici il serait plus en
prise du fou puisque le fou contrôler
les cases noires mais nous mais non
parce qu'il ya un pion aussi donc il
faut regarder bien les pièces voilà ses
pions qu'on vous a déjà expliqué il
prend donc sur les diagonales
donc si le roi va à gauche ou à droite
c'est la même histoire
il est menacé par une autre pièce ayant
prise alors est-ce que je peux aller sur
cette case là donc réfléchissez si vous
pouvez aller ici non et pourquoi parce
que le fou ici continuerai à attaquer le
roi ont regardé donc il serait toujours
en échec
donc on ne peut pas faire ce coup alors
autre possibilité je peux prendre le
pion imaginons que je prenne le pion si
je prends le pion je suis plus en échec
du fou mais il ya un autre problème ses
pions et protégé par un autre pion
donc vous ne pouvez pas capturer non
plus ses pions parce que l'autre pions
donc
prendre ce roi là ce pion métropole va
permettre de donc il ya plus beaucoup de
cases alors ici évidemment je suis
continue à être un échec du foot donc il
reste une case possibilité c'est celle
ci voilà je viens on évite donc là je il
ya plus d'échecs rendait le fou tape
dans le vide
le pied on ne fait pas échec puisqu'ils
contrôlent cette quasi ci ou celle là
mais certainement pas le roi il est
tranquille aucune autre pièce ne peut
prendre le roi sur cette case
donc on a paré l'échec alors ça c'est la
première façon oui je bouge le roi et je
me mets hors de danger alors au désiré
deuxième possibilité donc ça peut être
interposés mps milieu alors jeune
interpose parce qu'évidemment par
exemple si je lai le fou ici sur cette
case mais y'a plus échec pourquoi parce
que le foot ne peut pas prendre loin
puisque le fou n'a pas le droit de
sauter par-dessus fouille les cinq fois
aura droit de prendre c'est fou mais
dans ces cas on arrive à échanger les
pièces qu'on appelle comment vous
expliquer un peu plus tard quand on a
paré l'échec c'est un coup légal
oui voilà c'est un coup légal on a le
droit de faire ça et alors une troisième
possibilité qu'on voit par là mais qu'on
va revoir sur un autre échec
donc on revient sur la position initiale
et imaginons que les blancs jouent le
coup cavaliers sur la case
voilà mes seins alors ya échec au roi
malgré le fait qu'ils aient des pions
ici puisque comme on l'a vu dans les
leçons précédente le cavalier saute par
dessus les pièces il ne compte que la
case d'arrivée
on vous rappelle le principe le cavalier
sur cases blanches il va sur toutes les
cases noires qui sont à deux cases de la
classe de départ ou alors il va en elle
regardez le elle ici ou alors le elle
comme ça il peut évidemment en arrière
ou en avant donc en venant ici ils
menacent le cavalier au prochain coup de
venir sur cette case et donc comme le
roi et là il y à échec
et là on vous explique donc troisième
possibilité de empêcher que l'on reçoit
prise c'est éliminer cette pièce qui
attaquent le roi alors est-ce que je
peux éliminer le cavalier réponse oui
pourquoi regarder le petit jean desbiens
hop le pion peut prendre en diagonale ce
pion ici ce pion à 6 ici peut prendre
donc on va prendre le cavalier donc il
prend tac
lecavalier a disparu plus d'échec c'est
aux blancs de jouer et on peut pas
prendre le roi parce qu'il est petit et
de pièces alors on aurait pu aussi
choisir de bouger le roi par exemple
combien 8 ou en des 8 enfin le plus
efficace en l'occurrence ici c'est bien
de prendre le cavalier ce qui élimine
une pièce tout en parant l'échec
alors on va voir un autre exemple simple
d'échecs avec plusieurs plusieurs
possibilités de parer les chèques trois
possibilités sur tours g7
regardez ici la tour soit il fait peut
être pris en charge
voilà donc il faut parer les chèques
alors on peut prendre la tour le fouquet
s'est très bien sûr le signal voilà il
ya plus échec on berne interposés aussi
une pièce si on ennuie il est doux
possible il est d'ailleurs ici
d'interpréter soit le cavalier seul le
fou sur le cavalier ici regardez la tour
but maintenant sur le cavalier comme la
tour comme l inverse du cavalier ne
saute pas par dessus le cavaly fait bien
interceptions on peut prendre le cavaly
mais tout de suite on peut pas prendre
le roi donc il ya plus échec et on peut
mettre aussi le fou on a le choix qui a
protégé le roi moi c'est pareil et soit
donc déplacé qu'on le disait le roi sur
une autre et casse par exemple ici il
n'est pas sous soitec
voilà le roi ici n'est plus sur
l'attaqué de la tour le full ne
l'attaquent pas le cavalier ne
l'attaquent pas directement non plus y'a
pas échec c'est aux blancs de jouer il
pourrait faire un autre échec par
exemple en venant ici up en forêt un
échec au roi mais tout de suite c'est un
coût possible
on a paré l'échec immédiat de la torah
leur dernier petit échec possible dans
cette danse est parti on pourrait aussi
faire échec du pion ici il ya beaucoup
de possibilités échec dans ce cas là on
peut choisir soit de prendre avec le roi
ici soin de soi avec le cavalier soit
avec le fou et là vous voyez que les
pièces sont tellement proches de l'un de
l'autre il n'y a pas de possibilité
d'interposer quoi que ce soit si c'est
une pièce qui est juste à côté de qui
donc à côté droit qui vous attaquent
directement on va pas interposés entre
d'oka square ce soit pour rien mais n'y
a pas de case au milieu pour mettre
quelque chose donc on n'y a plus de
possibilité on peut aussi prendre ses
pions en même temps on peut très bien
prendre une autre pièce tout en enlevant
la regarde y'a plus de prise
donc ça c'est à noter vous pouvez très
bien par est un échec d'une pièce en
prenant une autre pièce c'est pas
interdit
oui ça c'est moment que quand vous avez
joué votre cou du moment que votre roi
n'est pas en prison
vous avez par et l'échec c'est aussi
simple que ça donc aussi à retenir donc
bien sûr
vous allez voir donc que l'euro est un
prisme sa dépendance est donc très haut
blanc au trou noir le tour qui est joué
parce que l'adversaire aux attaques
après c'est à vous de réagir pour donc
exactement utiliser des 3 3 de
possibilités comme la cité pourra
empêcher ça donc si c'est votre cou a
annoncé c'est le coût des jades adverse
et votre roue est toujours attaquer
alors que c'est à dire vous avez joué un
coup illégal entre entre temps c'est
déjà on est hors de jouer n'est que
normal c'est déjà comme illégal alors
autres possibilités dernière possibilité
de faire échec ici les dames ici peut
venir sur cette case ici et regardez
quand la dame va aussi comme un fou paf
il ya un échec au mans de la même façon
donc il faut parer les chèques dont
pareil on pourrait venir ici pas ici
pourquoi parce que la dame continuerait
de contrôler cette cassure des six ni
sur des six tours parier que la dame
contrôler toutes ses cadres donc on peut
pas bouger le roi mais on peut aussi
intercepté voilà ici le fou protège les
chèques a pas il ya plus l'échec puisque
les fous et en opposition
et donc mes chats dame d'attaqué de
prendre le roi donc on va terminer cette
position ne peut être avec pour les
noirs il est doux possibilité d'échec
aussi les noirs c'était le cil et blanc
joue un coup par exemple par exemple ici
n'importe quel cours et si ses traits au
noir cette fois alors il ya deux échecs
possible ici et vous voyez où mer noire
alors est-ce que ce cavalier pourrait
faire échec on voit bien que s'il vient
ici
ce cavalier il contrôle sept cases c4est
cette case ih 6e 4 ou cette case là donc
ils ne s'attaquent pas le roi n'ont donc
ça fait pas échec par contre le roi est
sûre cases noires donc regarder le fou
ici qui est sûre quasiment il pourrait
venir par exemple ici qui ragent 6 donc
si je me sers et regarder comme ça sur
les diagonales échec au roi soa sur ces
cinq soit sur l'autre côté on regarde et
hop pouf et là il ferait un échec pour
moi un très bel aussi très bel échec au
roi donc de l'autre côté
donc là on nous explique
donc là on a vu toutes les possibilités
d'échec je crois qu'on va voir
maintenant le matin oui si du temps
alors on va voir ici position alors on a
vu l'échec vous avez bien compris c'est
le roi qui est ont pris maintenant qu
est ce qu est ce que c'est qu'un échec
et mat très intéressant donc l'échec et
mat c'est la fin des parties et c'est le
cas où le roi et se menacer donc où le
roi est chic et il est plus de casse
pour il a uni casse pour s'échapper ni
ups pour interposés pour empêcher cet
échec et ils paient pas pour toucher
cette pièce pour capturer de l'attak
donc qui peut doit il va passer aucune
moyens et son échec et aucune moyenne il
est disons emprisonnés entre guillemets
et là on vous êtes perdant il faut il
faut abandonner il faut serrer la main
il faut serrer la main alors imaginons
commencé à la main regardez c'est aux
blancs de jouets ont regardé le roi ici
donc dans cette position on a aussi ses
traits au blanc on a maintenant un coup
alors est ce que vous voyez comment on
peut faire maths dans un coup dans cette
position alors aux antilles pour aider
si vous voyez pas encore alors stéphane
alors on va montrer lors dé la tour ici
donc on vous rappelle que la tour 20
tout droit soit devant soi sur arrière
les côtés soit en arrière et en
l'occurrence il ya un coût qui fait à la
fois échec mais aussi échec et mat
pourquoi alors parce que la touriste y
regarder contrôle attaques toutes ces
cases et donc le roi le roi noir
regardez donc le roi noir est en échec
le roi noir ne peut pas venir sur cette
caste qui continuent d'être contrôlé par
la tour non plus sur cette case puisque
la tour est là et il ne peut pas aller
manger ses propres pions ça c'est
interdit et donc toutes ces cases sont
interdites pour lui et donc regarder il
est totalement maths il ne peut plus
bouger
pas de possibilité évidemment si les
noirs avaient eu un fou sur cette case
il aurait pu prendre la tour mais y'a
rien donc on peut pas prendre la tour on
peut pas non plus l intercepter s'il y
avait eu un cavalier ici par exemple il
aurait pu venir sur cette case pour
parer les chèques mais y'a rien donc on
ne peut pas les intercepter ni prendre
la tour ni trouver une case de fuite
pour le roi noir
al'inverse à l'envers
et donc avec la matte la partie se
termine non voilà il faut serrer la main
et savoir vainqueur obtient un point et
le père donne zéro alors al'inverse
imaginons que les blancs jouent le coup
ne voit pas le maté joue le coutour on
va dire en oui en g3 ce coup là ici donc
il a le droit les blancs ont le droit de
faire ça sont pas obligés de mettre ma
ti n'ont peut-être pas vu et dans ce cas
là les noirs eux mêmes pourraient dire à
bea
mais je peux faire un chèque les maths
j'ai vert mat échec mais est-ce que
c'est matt
alors ici donc on fait évidemment un
échec au roi là c'est un peu la même
situation tout à l'heure regarder
évidemment on peut pas venir là on est
en échec
on peut pas venir là toujours à cause de
la tour on peut pas monter sur ses cases
là puisqu'un pions même aimé regarder
une petite fenêtre is it sorti donc on
peut encore jouer on peut pas prendre la
tour noire ont pas mais deux pièces au
milieu mais on paie donc déplacé leurs
os sur une case sur ouche où il n'est
pas attaqué et il ya plus d'échec c'est
panache de cette fois donc on voit bien
la différence alors ça c'est le sait le
fameux match du couloir quand vous en
montrer ça s'appelle ici
ces trois pions créer un couloir comme
on l'a vu gano mais puisque après tour b
regardez ici on a bien un échec et mat
de couloir le roi noir et pris
totalement pris et ne peut plus sortir
de son couloir alors que le roi blanc
lui là il s'était ménagé lors d'une
petite fenêtre de sortie ouf
il a évité ce matin donc c'est un match
ce qui arrive très classiquement oui
quand on est débutant donc que je veux
profiter d'une situation puisqu'on parle
de sa pensée dans vos parties créent une
petite fenêtre quand on voit pourquoi
dans le cas des blancs à fin d'année
paraît savoir le mode eco loire voilà
peut donc serbe pour c'est pour ça que
des fois dans les parties vous trouverez
ce genre de petit coup du côté noir ou
du côté blanc pour sauvegarder un petit
peu le roi et lui permettre d'échapper à
ce type de matériau crois qu'on a on a
fini pour cette leçon alors si nous
sommes très importantes vous avez
compris ce que c'est d'abord comment se
déplacent le roi amon ça c'était
relativement simple
qu'est ce qu'un échec ce qui est
fondamental hélas les trois façons de
paris en échec le ghana 3 papus prendre
la pièce mettre une pièce entre la pièce
qui fait échec et le roi quand c'est
possible quand la pièce est juste à côté
on peut pas parce qu'ils aient pas de
gaz entre les deux camps c'est un
cavalier on ne peut pas non plus mettre
une pièce à l'interception et le
troisième cas c'est évidemment fuir avec
le roi et trouver une case où là on
n'est pas en prise de l'adversaire alors
quand aucune de ces solutions n'est
possible eh bien on est échec et mat
et ça c'est le but du jeu d'échecs alors
c'est pas la seule issue possible
il peut aussi y avoir partie nulle aux
échecs oui ça ce sont d'autres cas
s'expliquer plus tard qu'on expliquera
plus tard elle est partie nulle c'est
quand les deux adversaires obtient le
déni points chacun - tommy pas là là on
verra ça sur une autre leçon voilà merci
aux nous de nous avoir éclairé sur et
bien les mouvements et les règles du roi
et de l'échec et de l'échec et mat
merci a bientot au revoir
[Musique]